[Music]
the oceans matter hugely
[Music]
you do over the land we don't realize go
straight out
our alien ocean is the biggest victim of
humanity's hubris
together we own the crisis and so
together we must come to face the music
[Music]
we all know time is running out we all
have a duty to act and a responsibility
to take action
[Music]
Mumbai India's city of dreams 18 and a
half million people living working
existing for Indians it's like every
dirt must go into the waterways
now the exact problem of plastic in
ocean is this now you come to the
plastic graveyard here in the ocean the
plastic graveyard yeah there is plastic
everywhere yeah
the pressures on this mega city are huge
but one of its greatest challenges is
not of its own making
this is devastation Thomas have you seen
so much plastic at a beach I've never
seen so much he has to get a beach this
isn't a beach it's horrendous horrendous
this is a rubbish dump yeah beach under
this tide of plastic is a beach of
golden sand waste not produced by the
city but brought in by the currents of
the Arabian Sea Afro Shah is an
award-winning eco warrior the waterways
around this fishing village once teemed
with life but slowly
they've been choked to death afros is
one of the delegates attending the our
ocean conference in Malta he's come here
to share his story with leaders from
more than 100 countries all have a
common purpose to save our oceans
littering starts with us spoiling of the
environment starts with us turning our
ocean is too severe has been done by us
each of us are responsible for you and
we must owner and when you own up he
will try to correct the situation this
is the fourth conference previous ones
have seen billions of pounds pledged to
protect our seas but money alone will
not save the oceans and the fragile
ecosystem that thrives there
in a little over 50 years we've become
almost totally dependent on plastic we
use some 320 million tons of it every
year but only 5% of it is effectively
recycled much of it ending up being
junked in our oceans
Prince Charles is a passionate
conservationist his love affair with the
sea started as a young boy and it grew
while it was a sailor in the Royal Navy
all these problems are accelerating and
multiplying at the same time and what we
try to please you don't wait until it's
a total disaster before you do something
it is a terrible aspect of human nature
that we we wait for proof so what I was
trying to say was we're testing the
world to destruction so another time you
have actually tested it and discovered
oh yes there's the evidence he's too
late
but but the oceans matter huge it but
the the problem is it's so I decided out
of mind what we do on the land we don't
realize go straight out to sea so all
the chemicals and pesticides and
everything else some nitrates we pour on
the land orders to be able to see very
often many parts that will form dead
zones and everything else one of the
princes key concerns is sustainable
fishing populations have been plundered
by unregulated overfishing and these
stocks need time to grow again but
there's also a real worry about ghost
nets discarded lines in gear continuing
to cause massive damage long after their
initial use has been served it's a
serious problem even here for the small
island that is hosting this year's ocean
conference this is some of the plastic
fishing gear that's been abandoned by a
trawler off the coast of malta after
snagging on a reef yet it continues to
catch marine life volunteer divers use
inflated bags to lift the nets to the
surface 500 kilos from one area in just
two days but it's nowhere near enough
worldwide 640 thousand tonnes of fishing
equipment is lost at sea every year this
has been done there probably for a few
years already because
there is some growth on it but you can
see that it's easy for animals to get
entangled in it often we find new nets
which has been done there for one or two
weeks already in those nets you plant so
much marine life getting a tangle and
attracting other animals what you need
to do is organize the fishing in a way
that enables the fish and everything
that the fish depend on to survive in
their ecosystems is called an ecosystem
based approach to fisheries management
is no good just letting people fish
everywhere with their bigger and bigger
boats with you know cleverer and
cleverer technology to find and suck up
every single last fish that's crazy
that's not conservation it's madness
well that's what's been going on and
I'll say you just stop fishing you have
to do it in a way that will actually
produce more fish for us all but by
managing it properly
Prince Charles talks about a blue
economy a business model that takes its
commitment to the aquatic environment
seriously and driven by this
understanding sky has continued with its
promise to put the environment at the
heart of what it does
plastic is flowing into our oceans at an
unprecedented rate we all know time is
running out we all have a duty to act
and a responsibility to take action now
skies ocean rescue campaign was launched
in January this year it's already
engaged with over six million people
plastic Asst a 10 meter whale made from
the same amount of plastic and enters
the ocean every second has toured the UK
helping to spread awareness the campaign
has seen many communities join forces
volunteers inspired and motivated to
join hands and organize local cleanups
Sky's chief executive officer Jeremy
Derrick has also announced a number of
key pledges that will not only see sky
continue to take the lead on
environmentally sound business practices
but help its business partners in supply
chain transform their operations first
of all that is a company we are going to
be free of single-use plastics by 2020
so right throughout our business whether
it's in our operations our supply chains
we will eliminate all single-use
plastics as a company really take the
lead in showing the way so in addition
to that we're doing two other things
first of all we're going to establish an
Innovation Fund anchored by our own
couple so we'll be putting in twenty
five million pounds of our own money to
work with young startups new businesses
to develop solutions to plastics in the
oceans and work with people who are
going to actually help us solve this
problem either by investing in those
businesses encouraging them potentially
giving them access to the sky in all of
our tables and then finally with WWF
we're going to be working on marine
protection areas
the idea of an ocean being killed by
plastic can be hard for some people to
really understand vast bodies of water
slowly choking on waste doesn't easily
translate as an environmental disaster
not in the same way as the death of a
single whale the idea that a discarded
bag of shopping could cause one of these
incredible animals to die a lingering
painful death illustrates the crisis in
our seas better than any statistic and
this stark realization is exactly what
happened to a small fishing community in
western Norway when a crew vias beaked
whale swam into a shallow inlet to die
first time it was behind a small boat
there this animal it was not healthy I
loaded my gun
I went down and I shot it we had a
researcher with us who was interested in
feeding habits of whales
I wanted to see what's actually in the
stomach as soon as we were able to see
what was inside it was we were all
shocked it was small looking like a
garbage bag just masses and masses of
plastic bags twisted into each other and
forming like one big big lump of plastic
to be honest I thought holy this is a
whale full of plastic it was just one
bag after the other handfuls of plastic
over 30 pieces and felt like it it's
endless really complete shopping bags
and wrappers and and and food bags
that's when it hit us but we had a
plastic well we all have a duty to help
preserve this planet for future
generations but perhaps it is they who
already understand exactly what is at
stake how will future generations ever
forgive us for destroying the viability
of the natural world that is our
ultimate sustainer you don't put a bit
on the beach you just clean up everybody
else's mess we're basically trying to
tackle plastic pollution in the range of
different ways we have four main goals
in our campaign and it's educating
inspiring clearing bottles of
supermarket shelves and just small
things like that
that can have a big change being the
future generation we saw that plastic
pollution was an issue that we're going
to inherit and being kids we just wanted
to try and make that plastic legacy a
smaller one as possible for when we grow
up the very fact that this conference is
taking place at all is proof that the
threat to our oceans from the plastic
tide is slowly being understood the
European Union has pledged five hundred
and sixty million euros to try and
tackle this
but money alone is not the answer it
will be down to each and every one of us
to understand that collectively every
action we take has major life destroying
consequences